the deputy who lost his job for not
confronting the Florida school shooter
apparently did not tell the truth about
his response deputy Scott Peterson
claimed he thought the shots were coming
from outside the building but a radio
recording released by the Broward County
Sheriff's Department indicates Peterson
knew the shots were coming from inside
the building the deadly shooting that
killed 17 people is leading students
from around the country to push for more
gun control but one student from
Stoneman Douglas High School is
launching his own effort to prevent
school shootings Calcasieu discussed his
ideas with President Trump yesterday and
he's joining us this evening thanks so
much for being here thank you for having
what was it like to meet the president
the first lady was quite amazing they
were so outgoing and welcoming and
really responsive did they did he know
the subject I mean did what what did he
ask you about of course she knew the
subject we we talked about what what
implementations and my opinions about
the subject and what I thought was best
to do now when you see and hear these
recordings what I mean I can't imagine
going through this and I'm sorry you
know as a young man that you had to go
through this but when you hear those
recordings and you know that there was
somebody armed with a gun there at the
facility what runs through your minds
when you hear that that recording look
it's absolutely terrible that they let
the students in the building be sitting
ducks well he had an armed weapon and he
could have went inside and he he let he
let the shooter roam free in the hall
was knowingly so it seemingly he waited
for everyone to simply just die in the
building only then to enter and that's
really heartbreaking what uh what do you
want to see happen what do you think
should really happen next well I think
of the stop prevention for violence Act
ISM extremely would have prevented this
completely and I'm really proud to say
that it's a bipartisan effort that's got
15 Democrats and 15 Republicans in favor
of it who signed up now you've actually
been up on Capitol Hill right met with
Senator hatch who else did you meet with
senator Rubio a speaker Paul Ryan and I
was senator Murphy
as well as a Senate Minority there Chuck
Schumer oh you got the a list well
that's that's good and what did you tell
him I mean what was your give me the
quick pitch what did you tell him we
needed to look I talked to every single
one about my concerns and opinions on
the Second Amendment and what we had to
do to protect it and I specifically said
that one Christmas Murph Murphy and we
discussed what had to be done although
we disagreed on what had to do for gun
control we did the senator we didn't we
get we did find a common ground and I
think that was most important as in we
represented that there was a bipartisan
effort to make a change and there are
issues to both the left and the right
can agree on so where is it that where
is the common ground where do you see
that there's actual agreement I think
the heart bill specifically shows that
do what does it say
I basically harden students at heart in
schools it gives the funding necessary
for the technological advancements to to
make sure we're safe and increases
communications between um the school and
law enforcement it makes proactive
prevention to make sure that we can
properly register students who are
having mentally ill or I'm having like
mental issues that might act out and in
the governor of Florida Governor Scott
signed a bill today into legislation do
you agree with that bill there is one
thing that's set out to mean it was a
bit concerned because right now we have
people in the military age 18 serving
and defending our country however we
don't protect our own citizens who are
illegal age to vote and have the mental
cognitive ability to vote to have the
same weaponry and I think that's really
hypocritical so you wouldn't you don't
believe that there should be two
different thresholds as to where you can
actually purchase a gun do you think the
gun that that lage should be higher or
should it be lower should be I think
right now if we were if a voter is able
to vote at age 18 that means we register
they have the cognitive ability the
proper cognitive development to do so
and if they have that cognitive ability
then they should be able to also have
the same rights as any other adult now
there's also some proposed legislation
or some thoughts on legislation that
there should be able to go out and get
some sort of restraining order on people
that can't distinguish right from wrong
you supportive of that or not support of
that well I'm really supportive in
making sure that people who have mental
disorders are not mentally stable cannot
acquire weaponry because at the end of
the day a bad guy if you're not mentally
stable you shouldn't have the gun and
you're developing an app to help with
this with do you have a name for it yes
sir it's called the reach out app and
what we're doing is we're allowing
students from the same school develop
emotional connections
solve their emotional issues in school
without any federal government funding
it's great the state of Utah's doing
that as well and there's there's an app
out there that we're students and 86
life saver 86 lives saved with this app
and Utah and I hope they duplicate it
around the country I'm sorry that you
and your cut your friends and you're too
young to have to gone through this but
thank you so much for being here thank
you thank you